We've talked in earlier lectures about perspective
projection. This is the transformation of
points in a three-dimensional world into a
two-dimensional image. And involves the loss
of a dimension it leads to artefacts such
as lines which are parallel in the three-dimensional
world appearing to converge in the two-dimensional
image or projection of that three-dimensional
world.
Another example here a bunch of parallel lines,
parallel three trunks which appear to converge
at a point. We talked early on about the pinhole
imaging model. We have a three-dimensional
scene and it projects into a two-dimensional
image. There is no unique inverse of the perspective
projection. Any number of different three-dimensional
models will lead to exactly the same two-dimensional
projection. The lack of a unique inverse is really important consequence of the perspective projection.
For robotics, knowledge of the three-dimensional
world is really important. A robot needs to
know how far away is the object did it wants
to grasp. A mobile robot needs to know whether
the space in front of it is free to be driven
in or whether there is an obstacle there.
So the important topic that we can uncover
in this lecture is how do we recover the third
dimension. That’s been lost in the perspective
projection process when we capture an image.